remember when vampires were scary so
does guillermo del toro the strain now i
didn't think i was gonna do a video on
this i don't usually cover premiere
episodes and stuff there's a couple of
reasons for that the first is I don't
catch a lot of premier episodes close to
when the air I'm a guy who by nature
tends to wait until the first season is
mostly done before jumping into
something because I just want to be here
it didn't get cancelled and then beyond
that I think first episodes are really
hard to judge a show by because first
episodes by their nature tend to be a
little bit out of whack with the rest of
the show because you they have to
establish everything they have to lay
the groundwork oftentimes they have to
throw a hook in there that isn't
actually typical of the show but it's
more likely to grab those initial
viewers and all this other stuff I don't
like to talk too much about first
episodes this one I do want to talk
about though for a couple reasons the
first is I just love gamble del Toro
I've never regretted seeing anything
he's done second thing is when a show
has the balls to come and do its first
episode in it's a hundred minutes long
you know what that's worth talking about
normally I try to avoid spoilers i'm
gonna talk about this episode fairly
freely cuz i mean it's the first episode
if you've read just the pitch of this
show you pretty much know everything
that's going to be going on and actually
you'll be ahead of the characters even
by the end of this episode cuz the
picture this thing is outbreak story
crossed with vampire story and what you
get really lines up with that now it was
really good call having guillermo del
toro direct this first episode because
the various components and the overall
where the thing seems to be headed is
not particularly unique its borrowing
heavily from various sort of plague
possibly zombie ish stories and
obviously vampire as well yeah well
there's always kind of aping himself a
bit there's a lot of the feel of Blade 2
in this thing so there's nothing in this
first episode of this kind of like blow
your mind oh I've never seen that before
but it's just assembled so well and is
presented so stylishly that is worth
watching even though you feel like maybe
I've kind of seen this and I like
knowing going into this thing that this
is going to be a mix of outbreak and
vampire
and it balances those two elements
really well the CDC going and dealing
with in just talking about how scary
pathogens are and all the precautions
they take when they don't know what's
causing the problem it's just all really
interesting is very well handles very
sciency but then there's all this other
aspects where you've got these ancient
characters and ancient devices and these
characters who have obviously been
around for a long time and dealing with
all sorts of stuff and some of them
clearly not human although you're not
entirely sure what their because we see
a number of different things creature
wise or at least in terms of things that
clearly aren't human so it becomes a
question of well are these all vampires
or some of them vampires are some of
them something else are some of them an
evolution of what vampires become are
there different strains of vampires you
don't really know and that's that's an
interesting aspect and there's a little
bit of ha I'll be interested to see the
what the answers to this are I like the
cast you most of the characters fit out
very clear mold is nobody is really
outside the box in terms of the
characterization or the casting but it's
it's all just really solid choices the
standouts for me and maybe it's just
because I recognized them from other
stuff but I like Sean Astin a sort of
the techy guy he's got that sort of
high-energy slightly on edge kind of
fields on that you like from the techy
sort of character also there's David
Bradley who best known as filched from
the Harry Potter movies aura as this
bastard from Game of Thrones playing the
sort of Abraham Van Helsing type
character at least that's the vibe we
get on him heck they even named him
Abraham so I'm pretty sure that's what
they're going for but he's the guy who
seen this before and he knows what needs
to be done but no one's gonna listen to
him at least not yet our main character
Ephraim Goodweather sort of the head of
the CDC I'd like him I get a good feel
off of him I don't love the fact that
they initially set him up as the
absentee father and he's going through a
separation and probably a divorce and
cuz he's always at work he's never I did
I don't need those story beats to
connect with this character I connect
with this character much more when he's
on the job working he's working this
problem he's working this disease and I
connected with him so much more than
this artificial family unit drama
stuff they saddled him with which I feel
is a kind of the one danger area of the
show I feel like that might tie the guy
down in a way that is not particularly
interesting but thankfully as far as
balancing goes that did not take out but
an exceptional amount of the runtime it
speaking of runs on I got to come back
to the fact that this thing is an hour
and 40 minutes long a little bit less
when you take out for commercials but
still I really like that they did that
because what makes this episode work
this first episode is the way that it's
paste in the amount of atmosphere and
just the vibe you get off that thing and
a lot of that vibe comes from the fact
that it takes its time moving forward
initially and if they had done you know
a standard one-hour episode the thing
either would have been rushed or would
have been cut off in the middle and a
you would've felt incomplete so props to
FX for committing to this long first
episode to just get everything in the
right place moving forward the creature
concepts and effects and all the various
little squiggly little bits that were
dealing with their creepy their
unnerving you don't get a great look at
a lot of this stuff so there's a lot of
review to just kind of get skeeved out
by the fact that you're not sure
entirely what you're dealing with I mean
we know it's vampiric but aside from
that this is this is a different kind of
vampire but at its heart it's a scary
vampire and it's about time because
we've been dealing with romantic
vampires almost non-stop since interview
with a vampire in the 90s then twilight
took it over and even true blood while
it's distinctly different from Twilight
it's still at its heart a romantic
version of vampires no more romance
they're here to kill us and they're
gonna do it viciously and gruesomely and
I for one am enjoying seeing that I'm
really kind of hooked into the show and
I'm gonna keep watching it it's very
unlikely that i'll be doing episode by
episode reviews on this thing odds are
i'll probably lay low in terms of videos
until we get to the end of c's and then
i might do a season overview but i guess
i first episode really strong stuff and
if you're into horror particularly if
you're into the sort of creature gothic
horror which is right in my wheelhouse
that's the kind of horror i love you're
gonna dig the heck out of this thing so
if you haven't seen it already watch it
and get
caught up for when the next episode airs
you'll be happy that you did so I'll
throw it out there favorite vampire TV
show anything from Buffy to Dark Shadows
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it and until next time
this council is a jerk